en las afueras de bahamut la 24aba
brigada ucraniana se adentra en el
bosque se dice que las posiciones rusas
están a solo 300 metros por delante
detrás del avance ucraniano una segunda
unidad proporciona fuego de cobertura
lo hacemos por la mañana disparándoles
con todo lo que tenemos para
perturbarlos lo más posible para que no
tengan ganas de levantarse o incluso de
atacar
fue capturada por las fuerzas rusas en
mayo tras ocho meses de combates la
batalla más larga del conflicto la
contra ofensiva ucraniana se está
produciendo al norte y al sur de la
Ciudad dicen que han recuperado 50
metros de terreno hasta ahora
por el momento no hay movimiento por la
noche Es cuando están más activos se oye
El ruido de su equipo y si hablan alto y
el tiempo está en calma también se les
Oye
al otro lado de la línea del frente que
se extienda a lo largo de mil kilómetros
kiev Dice que están progresando afirma
que hasta ahora han recuperado ocho
pueblos el último hoy las banderas
sondeaban en el asentamiento de Epic
gatchie en el sur de saporilla
Rusia perderá los territorios que ocupa
no habrá alternativa a la liberación de
nuestra tierra
Mientras tanto Los jefes militares rusos
afirman que están infligiendo daños
catastróficos a las fuerzas ucranianas y
que la ofensiva de kiev ha perdido
impulso los últimos análisis militares
de Estados Unidos y el Reino Unido
sugieren que ambos bandos están
sufriendo grandes pérdidas y que Ucrania
aún no ha desplegado todas sus fuerzas
en la batalla